Almost every superhero has an evil opposite.
Spider-Man has Venom, Superman has Bizarro,
and Shazam the hero formerly known as Captain
Marvel has the deadliest of them all: Black
Adam.
Powered by the same mystical lightning that
makes his nemesis so formidable, Adam has
all of Shazam's powers, and is far more ruthless
in using them.
He's easily one of DC's most popular villains,
but that wasn't always the case.
Here’s the untold truth of Black Adam!
Black Adam appears
To say that Captain Marvel was popular in
the '40s might be the biggest understatement
in superhero history.
Captain Marvel Adventures legendarily outsold
Superman, and in 1945, Fawcett launched yet
another comic for Cap and his sidekicks that
would run for 89 issues: The Marvel Family.
For the launch of a new magazine, Otto Binder
and C.C.
Beck knew they needed a pretty big story,
so they put a new spin on an idea they’d
already tried with a villain named IBAC who
was powered by history’s greatest evils.
In "The Mighty Marvels Join Forces," they
revealed that Billy Batson wasn't the first
mortal to wield the power of Shazam.
The original was Teth-Adam, an Egyptian man
who lived 5,000 years ago, and who was chosen
for what the wizard saw as the purity of his
soul.
Unfortunately, power corrupts, and being the
most powerful person on Earth quickly went
to Adam's head.
After snapping a Pharaoh's neck a bit of violence
that's pretty shocking by Shazam standards
Adam was exiled by the wizard to "the farthest
star," from which it coincidentally took him
about 5,000 years to return.
When the Marvel Family tricked him into saying
"Shazam," all that time caught up with him,
and Teth-Adam quickly aged so fast that he
turned to dust before their eyes.
And believe it or not, that's how he stayed
for the next 30 years.
Back in Black
After crumbling to dust in 1945, Black Adam
wasn't seen again until DC started publishing
Shazam in the '70s with the title changed
because Marvel Comics had snapped up "Captain
Marvel" in 1967 for their own cosmic hero.
In Shazam #28, Dr. Sivana (with an assist
from Otto Binder and legendary Superman artist
Kurt Schaffenberger) employed a "Reincarnation
Machine" to bring Adam back to life and set
him loose to destroy Boston.
Unfortunately for Adam, his second outing
wound up going exactly the same way as his
first one, right down to being tricked into
saying "Shazam."
This time, though, he stuck around long enough
to cement himself as one of the Shazam family's
greatest foes.
What's in a (magic) name?
If you're up on your comics trivia, you're
probably aware that Shazam's magic word gave
him the attributes of six mythological patrons:
the wisdom of Solomon, the strength of Hercules,
the courage of Achilles, the power of Zeus,
the stamina of Atlas, and the speed of Mercury.
Considering how similar they are, you might
assume that Black Adam drew from the same
sources for his own powers, but that turned
out to not be the case.
When Billy realized that being 5,000 years
old put Black Adam squarely before the time
of wise King Solomon, the wizard explained
that he was powered by Egyptian deities, with
the stamina of Shu, the strength of Hershef,
the power of Amon, the wisdom of Zehuti, the
speed of Anpu, and the courage of Menthu.
If a few of those don't sound too familiar,
well, that’s because Binder fudged it a
little, using lesser-known names for a few
of the gods.
Zehuti and Anpu, for instance, are definitely
more well known as Thoth and Anubis.
As for why he bothered to change Anubis, when
it already fit the acronym, your guess is
as good as ours.
Theo Adam and the Power of Shazam
In 1987, the Shazam Family was formally inducted
into the DC Universe following Crisis on Infinite
Earths, but with all his similarities to Superman,
it didn't really work until writer/artist
Jerry Ordway relaunched The Power of Shazam
in 1994.
One of Ordway's biggest changes in updating
Captain Marvel for the '90s came from the
way he reimagined Black Adam.
He was the first creator to make Adam into
the book's primary villain from the start
not just for Captain Marvel, but for Billy
Batson, too.
Rather than just being an ancient Egyptian
warrior, Ordway's take gave the villain a
modern-day secret identity: Theo Adam, a greedy
archaeologist who accompanied Billy’s parents
on a dig, and eliminated them in a fit of
rage in order to get his hands on a priceless
artifact.
Even worse?
That artifact allowed him to transform into
Black Adam, becoming Captain Marvel's first
and greatest arch-nemesis.
Not only was he his evil opposite, he was
also the guy who took his parents from him,
mixing a touch of Batman into Billy's origin.
In 1999, Ordway would add another interesting
twist when Adam started saving people, and
even turned himself into the Justice League,
claiming to be innocent of Theo Adam’s crimes.
In both an earthly courtroom and a mystical
trial, he proved that Theo Adam and Teth-Adam
were actually two different people who happened
to share a body due to the wizard's magic,
and that every evil act had been done under
Theo's influence before Teth-Adam had been
able to regain control.
With that, Adam was reformed… more or less.
While he still occasionally found himself
operating as a supervillain due to Theo’s
lingering influence, Adam was heroic enough
that he even joined the Justice Society of
America.
The ultra-violent king of Kahndaq
Remember how Black Adam's very first appearance
in 1945 started off with him snapping a dude's
neck and taking over his country?
Despite his seeming reformation, that tendency
towards shocking on-panel violence was something
that remained a part of Adam's character all
the way through the modern age and in the
21st century, it was ramped up to the extreme.
His most famous act of ridiculously over-the-top
brutality came when he shoved the Psycho Pirate's
eyes through the back of his head, but he
also vanquished Terra from the Teen Titans
by punching through her torso, and at one
point, after being stripped of his powers,
even resorted to cannibalism.
The idea, it seems, was to make him as dark
as Shazam was bright, but it's easy to argue
that creators of that era went too far.
When Black Adam was rebooted once again in
2011, he was still undeniably villainous,
but that level of blood and gore was apparently
left behind.
If you smell what Black Adam's cookin'
The biggest piece of Black Adam news to come
along… well, ever, has undoubtedly been
the casting of Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson in
DC's cinematic universe.
In 2014, after years of speculation, it was
revealed that Johnson will be taking on the
role of Teth-Adam, perhaps making his first
appearance in the sequel to Suicide Squad.
As exciting as that is, it's also pretty surprising
for Johnson to be cast as the villain.
Shazam is based on the childhood power fantasy
of a kid who can transform into the coolest
adult he can imagine.
With that in mind, he seems like a much more
natural fit for the hero what kid wouldn't
want to say a magic word and turn into the
Rock?